it was the middle of the night on may
12th when this hospital in goa hit a
breaking point i got an sos message from
one of the doctors at gmc the hua
medical college she
reported that she had no oxygen coming
in the central pipeline of her world
about two o'clock we got through some
officials and they told us nothing like
this was happening at all the doctor
took a video of the entire board with
all the ventilator and i see machines
beeping
an hour later the police arrived and
confirmed that the oxygen in the
pipeline was fluctuating
that night at least 20 people died due
to lack of oxygen the next day the issue
blew up on social media
and that's when we came to know from the
doctors that this was not that night
issue it has been happening since two
months it began in april 2021 when india
experienced a sharp increase in
coronavirus cases with hundreds of
thousands of daily new infections the
country's been registering some of the
highest cases in the world
and when these cases went up
so did the demand for life-saving oxygen
but india hasn't been able to match that
demand
and that's added avoidable deaths to a
second wave of covet 19 that has
devastated the country
in may more than 70 covet patients died
as a result of the oxygen crisis at the
hospital in goa
the same thing has been happening across
india hospitals have seen covet patients
die because they ran out of oxygen
and they started turning people away
many were forced to wait in line for
hours to fill oxygen cylinders for sick
family members
this shortage seems to have caught india
off guard and has made the news in this
pandemic
but the thing is
india has run out of oxygen before
so
why does this keep happening
[Music]
first let's look at how the oxygen
industry works in india
about 85 percent of the oxygen produced
ends up in commercial industries like
steel or pharmaceuticals and about 15
percent is sent to hospitals for medical
purposes
[Music]
this map shows where india's medical
oxygen manufacturing plants are
concentrated around the country
india moves that oxygen from one point
to another through a large and complex
supply chain that spans several states
and thousands of hospitals
here's what that typically looks like it
starts in the manufacturing plants where
oxygen is extracted from the air and
turned into liquid that oxygen is sent
to big jumbo tankers for storage
from there it's sent to distributors
where liquid oxygen is compressed into a
gas ready to be used
it's then funneled into tankers or
smaller cylinders and sent to local
suppliers who then send oxygen to
hospitals local vendors or directly to
patients
some big hospitals skip local suppliers
they store liquid oxygen in tanks on
site
the steps in the supply chain seem
simple enough the problem is the
distance between one point and another
and that makes transportation one of the
weakest links in this supply chain
nationwide
most of the manufacturers and suppliers
concentrated in these states don't
deliver oxygen outside of a 50-kilometer
radius
the ones who do charge extra
even then long distances can compromise
the oxygen making hospitals around the
country vulnerable to oxygen crises
especially in states over here far from
the manufacturers i mean none of us
could have predicted the acute oxygen
shortage that we faced this year but
right of this at the start of the
pandemic you know it was evident
at how district hospitals in farflung
areas you know already were you know
they were not very equipped
in 2017 this state-run hospital in uttar
pradesh was treating dozens of
critically ill children during a viral
outbreak that august this tank holding
the hospital's liquid oxygen ran out
the hospital's oxygen came all the way
from rajasthan about 800 kilometers away
so it took three days to restore the
supply
but
by then at least 60 children had died
an investigation by the wire revealed
that the oxygen ran out because the
supply had been cut off
the state government had ignored
payments for months
the meter showed the oxygen supply was
stopped due to low pressure
but the state government called it an
act of god and didn't take
responsibility
but the government did little to fix the
gaps in the oxygen supply chain
three years later kovid reached india
and the daily consumption of medical
oxygen gradually tripled
for months the government received
warnings of an impending oxygen shortage
and recommendations that plans be made
to produce adequate oxygen
finally the government took bids to
build
162 new oxygen plants at all these major
hospitals
these plants would produce oxygen
on-site for sick patients
and keep the fragmented supply chain
from getting further strained
but around the same time as the result
of a series of lockdowns infection rates
started to drop
by february prime minister modi started
encouraging everyone to return to normal
life at their own risk i also urge
you all
to use this time and travel
to end many as nearby areas as possible
and in april when cases started to
quickly climb up again
[Music]
he was out campaigning heavily ahead of
state elections
bringing tens of thousands of people
together at political rallies
meanwhile this deadly wave was sweeping
across the country killing thousands a
day we saw the most devastating and the
most gruesome images rows and rows of
bodies at the cremation ground
that was how stark the disconnect was
when people are dying this is what is
the priority
of people from the ruling party
the government's misplaced priorities
and lack of vigilance emboldened
thousands to attend mass events
even though the second wave of kovid
raged on and reached some of the highest
case numbers in the world
as covid cases surged the need for
oxygen went up again
major hospitals around the country began
seeing thousands of covet patients show
up at their doors for treatment there
were hospitals that would
tweet to say that we're running out of
oxygen we don't have enough oxygen to
sustain our patients for the next two
hours i request you please send oxygen
to us we need oxygen for our patients
investigations revealed that the
government had failed to keep its
promises
out of the 162 oxygen plants promised by
the government only 33 were functional
that really begs the question of what
was the government doing
during 2020 they had celebrated a
premature victory against the pandemic
as india recorded the highest cases in
one day anywhere in the world these
oxygen gaps became even more dangerous
india's daily deaths although
significantly under reported were in the
thousands across the country
but now there were hundreds of
additional deaths due to lack of oxygen
like in delhi where in one weekend at
least 50 people died due to lack of
oxygen
or in maharashtra
or in goa's medical college where the
central government promised to build an
oxygen plant that didn't come gmc did
not have an oxygen plant of its own so
they were basically manually putting
cylinders and connecting it to make sure
that the oxygen was reaching in the
central pipeline the high court had to
instruct the centre government to
intervene and put up a plant and now
it's been operational within like seven
eight days but it took them so many
lives which have died because of lack of
oxygen
to meet the rising demand for medical
oxygen nearly all industries redirected
their supply to hospitals
the government enlisted the indian air
force and railways to deliver it and
countries around the world sent
equipment and tanks filled with oxygen
to help
but these are just temporary fixes for a
supply chain that still struggles to
transport oxygen that needs to reach
everyone across the country in a crisis
the government has promised a thousand
more oxygen plants to fill the gaps
but has yet to complete the original 162
it promised it's not people have lost
their lives because of coronavirus
they've lost the lives because of
politics they've lost their life because
of displaced priorities of the
government
but what's happening here isn't a
uniquely indian problem
as coveted waves continue oxygen
shortages have become a problem in
countries like nepal sudan and argentina
in fact dozens of other countries need
more oxygen
especially in the global south where low
vaccination rates are leaving millions
vulnerable to infection
not all countries will face a
humanitarian crisis like india's
but india didn't think it would either
and failed to prepare when cases were
low
dr fauci what can we learn from india's
outbreak don't ever underestimate the
situation the situation in india is a
devastating reminder
of what this virus can do it's very
important to realize that the situation
in india can happen
anywhere
[Music]